cómo
vamos
hola buenos días qué nervios no me
imaginé cuando me contó jay jay que iba
a dar una plática que iba a estar en
frente de todos ustedes aquí en un
círculo rojo pero bueno muchas gracias
por la invitación estoy feliz de poder
estar aquí con ustedes tan feliz que
cambie mi vuelo hoy para venir hoy en la
mañana y estar aquí estoy karla martínez
de salas hoy director editorial de vogue
méxico y latinoamérica muchos no saben y
nos preguntan que hay son dos revistas y
si son dos revistas diferentes las
hacemos aquí de méxico ambas revistas
con colaboradores para latinoamérica
este año cumplimos 20 años estamos
celebrando todo el año y en esta
conversación de los 20 años este pues
tengo a dos editores y barbara terán
subdirectora y claudia valdez director
editora de belleza pero siempre
platicamos todos los editores y todas
los de la revista porque somos un equipo
bastante chico de los 20 años y qué
significa no sólo vos creés
latinoamérica
realmente cómo ha cambiado la industria
de la moda cuando yo empecé a trabajar
no les voy a decir mi edad podría
adivinar empecé en belgrado en 1999 y me
fui a vivir a parís un año y después me
fui a vivir a nueva york es en el 2000
fue como el primer boom donde mucha
gente cerraron muchas empresas y hubo
esta incertidumbre que un poco estamos
sintiendo de los últimos años este yo
afortunadamente conseguí un trabajo en
nueva york en una revista y platicando
cuando yo empecé era de mandar tu
currículum por email acababa de empezar
no era tan yo tenía una cuenta de yahoo
que seguramente nadie tiene aquí una
cuenta y uno aunque no debería decir eso
pero este cambio ha cambiado muchísimo
ahorita me puede se puede comunicar
conmigo directo por instagram por
diferentes medios no esté eso yo he
visto la evolución de la moda en estos
últimos 20 años entonces platicando un
poco con las editoras decíamos yo les
contaba un poco y en mi carta de marzo
lo platiqué un poco de que es una chica
bond aunque es una mujer bold quienes
bou quien es un hombre que sale en boga
y yo por mis propias este por mis
propios prejuicios decían no pues es que
para trabajar en google en medios en
moda tienes que ser alta flaca güera de
pelo lacio una vez a la semana me vas a
secar el pelo porque como que no se me
sentía mejor cuando tenía el pelo lacio
y en esta conversación platicamos
muchísimo y nos quisimos enfocar mucho
en la bella
y lo que quiere decir estar en bowie y
el significado y en el año pues
empezamos a trabajar en la estrategia de
este año este y decidimos platicarles y
yo les quería platicar porque hay mucho
que les podría practicar pero empoderar
la vella y sant boi es lo que es lo que
decidimos que sería increíble porque en
estos 20 años
estamos celebrando a la mujer
lo que es bueno aquí tengo una
presentación
pero les platico un poco del año en
enero empezamos en enero de este año y
en cómo movieron cada persona cuando yo
primero entre la revista como que
decíamos ahí no pues vamos a poner su
amor o de rusia tu amor o de no sé dónde
y cómo que veíamos que pues sí que
jalaban en redes y si la gente le
gustaba y si les gustaba ver una imagen
una mujer súper guapa que salía en todas
las pasarelas pero el año pasado
empezamos como que a decir y si sacamos
hay tanto pasando en méxico hay tanto
pasando en latinoamérica que porque no
hablamos de lo que está pasando aquí
porque ahorita yo cuando empecé a
trabajar si querías ver vogue italia si
querías ver bow japón
usted tenía la tenías que comprar si
viajaba aquí igual y ensamble está
tenían no estaba tan accesible como lo
es ahora ahorita te subes a cualquier
página de vogue y puedes ver su portada
entonces realmente hablamos de qué
quiere decir esto pues cualquier persona
quiere decir puede ver voz méxico y
puede ver voz latinoamérica
por qué no celebrar lo que tenemos en
nuestro país y en latinoamérica que es
enorme y si es un chalet muchas veces
porque en latinoamérica pues en
argentina si vas ahorita están entrando
invierno si vas mucha de la gente es muy
europea si vas a colombia tienes una
mezcla de diferentes culturas este
entonces realmente es como nos hemos
enfocado mucho decir ok este mes vamos a
hablar un poco de venezuela de colombia
de chile de argentina y pues para méxico
de méxico pero también lo que está
pasando en latinoamérica en septiembre
del año pasado en agosto me editora de
agenda y mundo regina montemayor me
preguntó oye me están buscando de
netflix por la película de cuarón este
no quiero poner a la lista en portada y
le dije número no quién es ya lista y
número dos como a poner una persona
completamente desconocida en mi portada
me van a decir nos van a decir que que
estamos pensando bueno pues me fui a
nueva york en la tarde me puse a pensar
y dije sabes que dicen que esta película
la habana nominada para el oscar
es la primera vez actuando porque no
ponerla en portada y pensamos la
producción y la fotografía mos en
octubre con un equipo 100 mexicano que
nos dio muchísimo gusto y pues en eso
empezamos la conversación de este año no
debimos aisa gonzález que es una de las
mexicanas que realmente está haciendo
muchísimas películas en hollywood y en
california ha trabajado muchísimo en
habla en efecto para que él no digan ah
no tú tienes que ser la mexicana en la
película o la colombiana o x este line y
si montero que es una dominicana que ya
hemos sacado en vogue antes pero me
decía en cuando la vivencia es que antes
las niñas en república dominicana no se
soltaba en el pelo no querían que la
gente os hace tener un afro era de que a
no esto te lo vas a lanzar porque así no
sales en la portada una revista y
nosotros la sacamos con su afro con su
pelo chino hermoso y me dijo que
muchísima gente le ha dicho gracias
por hacerme sentir como puedo salir de
mi casa así y verme bonita y no tan que
caer en este estereotipo de tener pelo
lacio o tener que poner una peluca
un poco hablando de la conversación y de
lo que les decía de que es una mujer
folk que es alguien que por ejemplo nos
decían bueno esa ella no es voz no puede
salir en la portada pues quiere decir y
ahora creo que ha cambiado muchísimo no
sólo un poco pero en todos los medios no
lo que vemos y gracias a las redes
podemos ver todo tipo de belleza y pues
la verdad es que evoluciona como ha
evolucionado la perspectiva de las
mujeres que nos representan en boca
pensamos en unas palabras disruptivas
emblemáticas arriesgadas emprendedoras
seguras de sí mismas y mismos mamás
padres hermanas hijas solteras casadas
valientes divertidas espontáneas y con
carácter esto creo que es algo súper
importante cuando estamos pensando en
que quieren ver ustedes en la revista
esto de la lista nos abrió muchísimo los
ojos y el imas fue un gran aprendizaje
porque
cuando veíamos los comentarios de la
gente decía gracias por poner a alguien
que se parece a mí en la portada eso es
muy fuerte porque yo soy de padres
mexicanos creciendo eeuu en lugares
donde no había muchos mexicanos y luego
en lugares donde sí había muchos
mexicanos y llegas y dicen ay no sé si
les han dicho pero youtube
mexican a waters mexican duct like no
entonces es un poco hablar de esto de
cómo pues no hay un estereotipo no no
abrir los ojos a de que este tipo de
comentario ya no es del 2019 ya no es ya
no pertenece a este a la conversación a
lo que está pasando socialmente
en nuestra edición de belleza que la
edita la editora de belleza claudia
valdez platicamos mucho nos peleamos
mucho por no pues yo quiero poner allá
no pues porque la quieres poner bueno en
los últimos años y hemos cosas hecho
cosas divertidas este con gente
mediática que nos da de qué platicar
el año pasado el año antepasado pusimos
a candice huffine que fue la primer
modelo plas ice que hemos sacado en la
revista este bueno en portada de la
revista hace un en el 2017 fui a un
desfile de moda de un diseñador hindú
que se llama prabal gurung y él puso a
muchos modelos las face en la pasarela
que fue el primer primer fue cuando
estaba pasando todo esto de michu y fue
como el primer diseñador en atreverse a
hacer este cambio al no sacar a la flag
y sima anglosajona en su pasarela
entonces como que le aplaudió mucha
gente y creo que abrió una conversación
de ser más inclusivos
me siento ahorita en las pasarelas este
último esta última temporada que fue
nueva york milán y parís y ahí está
inclusividad ya no son o sea ya se
siente raro cuando ves un desfile y hay
pura güera flaquísima que no te
relacionas con ella ahora siempre tratan
bueno en lo que yo he visto en los
diseñadores están mezclando a niñas que
quieren ser hombres hombres que quieren
ser niñas modelos plazas negras morenas
hueras es una mezcla realmente y el año
para el año pasado el año antepasado
pusimos a que andes en portada
en noviembre del 2018 pusimos aquí
entrar ayer en portada que estaba
lanzando su línea de maquillaje este si
quieren verme hizo mi maquillaje en el
shooting de cómo hacer contour en 5
minutos que fue algo súper súper
divertido y a la vez fue un gran
aprendizaje porque haces cosas en redes
y te expones a que te digan por qué no
te pintaste pues según ella me estaba
pintando ella ya mí no esté pero actor
mujer que creo que han hecho han roto
estos estereotipos a luz pavón el año
pasado en octubre del 2018 también para
el especial de belleza
estamos sacando en el libro 'the times'
que yo dije bueno va a ser un boom va a
ser todo un éxito y médico claudio oye
qué te parece si sacamos a la luz que es
mexicana y hemos hecho bastantes cosas
con ellas y la sacamos en portada y dije
bueno pues luz pavón que es una mexicana
de pelo chino morena divina tuvo mucho
más éxito que me libra de 200 ahí vamos
aprendiendo un poco de las audiencias y
de lo que quieren ver
de lo que quieren ustedes de lo que es
importante y todo es así de a igual
mexicana hacia las campañas de batman el
pelo y es una gran amiga de nosotros y
me dio muchísimo gusto que la pudimos
celebrar así
el año pasado también hicimos un revista
para este año hicimos un rediseño del
sitio web que espero que lo vean todo un
mundo book punto mx que es mucho más
fácil de usar pero no hemos podido e
hicimos este rediseño en marzo del año
pasado y hablando del rediseño quisimos
empezar esta conversión no porque sólo
puede poner modelos han escuchado la
canción de habana me dijo un editor y un
editor de la oficina y le dije pues sí
creo que así como que si le escuchado la
verdad es que yo necesito que los
jóvenes me platiquen un poco de lo que
está pasando por el mundo este y
decidimos poner a camila cabello en
portada que es de papás cubanos pero
creció en méxico hasta los 10 años y
bueno pues su canción fue un éxito este
no sólo no sólo un éxito porque canta
osa canta en español también pero porque
llegó a los grammys y ya como han visto
y como saben los latinos están
revolucionando la música también
y ella es muy orgullosa de haber vivido
en méxico de ser de padres latinos su
mamá viaja a todas partes con ella es
una mujer que realmente sí es es lo que
es hoy no es muy fuerte tiene una
opinión y se presta para muchas cosas
entonces estuvimos muy emocionados de
que antes de la lista camila fue una de
las portadas más difundidas en la
historia de boca en agosto pusimos a
chistoso que es una celebridad argentina
que la verdad es que yo no sabía quién
era porque no era de mi generación yo no
veía ese programa de violeta que creo
que todas las niñitas lo han visto este
y ahora es una cantante súper exitosa en
argentina y también fue de estas cosas
de que la ponemos en la portada de latam
ir por todas partes 98% los comentarios
súper positivos de que ahí pongan a más
mujeres así más mujeres que inspiran
tiene un mensaje súper lindo y sigue
sigue cantando y sigue
actuando y conociendo cosas increíbles
en noviembre pusimos a salma hayek en
portada que fue la segunda vez que ha
salido en bone
quisimos hacerla muy natural yo fui al
footing y les cuento algo chistoso que
ella estuvo de repente yo estaba viendo
la ropa algo así y me dice carla y bolt
y dije quinto sin estar hablando salma
pues me está hablando a salma y quería
platicar y me platicaba que anduvo con
el papado una editora de vogue este que
se nos hizo muy chistoso pero realmente
lo que hicimos capturar muy natural y
muy como la mujer muy fuerte que es y la
verdad es que cada vez que cubrimos
cosas de salma sus películas sus
proyectos este a la gente le encanta le
encanta leer de ella le encanta leer
como ella tuvo una situación que la
volvió positiva y bueno es obviamente es
alguien que nos inspira y también es una
mujer que no tiene 25 años y que también
fue una de las portadas más difundidas
de la historia de la revista y llegamos
allá lisa que fue fotografiada por
santiago y mauricio cierra dos
fotógrafos mexicanos donde la ocampo una
editora mexicana y bueno regina
montemayor de boat
e hizo toda la producción y que vio todo
el proyecto y realmente pues sí sí fue
algo que no nos espera o sea yo sí me
esperaba en la primer foto que subimos
de ella que tuvimos muchísimo muchísimos
comentarios de cuando la portada que la
sacamos en noviembre cuando sacamos la
portada en diciembre desde el día que la
sacamos hasta marzo te juro tenía
comentarios diarios de gente que me
estira oye viste esto viste que salió en
gym y que no viste que salió yo no me
esperaba tal impacto que tuvo pero como
les platicaba antes los comentarios que
recibíamos en las gracias por poner a
ella lista en portada gracias por poner
un indígena y por apostar por poner una
mujer que nunca había salido enfoque
ninguna boca había sacado algo así y no
sólo en méxico sino en eeuu en
diferentes partes de latinoamérica fue
realmente un gran orgullo para nosotros
para poder hacer un proyecto así este
todos las nuevas generaciones que están
con las que estamos hablando siento que
esto es
mensaje de la inclusividad de hacer
cosas positivas de hacer artículos que
realmente ustedes se puedan llevar algo
y que no tengan una fecha de expiración
si quieren conocer de novedades de las
de noticias pueden ir a book ponte mx
pero realmente en la revista queremos
platicar de cosas que les los sociales
que le están impactando a ustedes en su
vida vida diaria y que no tienen fecha
de expiración
los dejo con este vídeo que hicimos de
la lista que cuando primero lo vi tuve
que se me salieron las lágrimas porque
realmente es fue algo súper lindo
escucharla hablar y no la conocíamos
también después tuvimos la oportunidad
de hacer algo con ella en oaxaca ya la
conocemos un poco mejor pero pero se los
pongo este para que lo vean si no lo han
visto y empiece una serie nueva con
estos vídeos
hablemos de mí
del papel que interpretó en una película
que refleja la realidad hablemos de
mujeres reales con nostalgias recuerdos
pasiones y una identidad que se ve y se
siente a flor de piel
mi piel muy mexicana
oaxaca y muy humana del color de mi
tierra y la diversidad de sus colores
[Música]
luces cámaras alfombras rojas portadas
es por esperanza por realzar el nombre
del lugar de origen por inspirar
creo que lo más bello que te puede pasar
en la vida es trascender a través de las
personas no de uno mismo
[Música]
mi nombre es ya lisa aparicio martínez y
estoy en la portada de vogue
[Música]
de nuevo muchas gracias a su suerte
cómo
x